now the Border standoff is escalating
Governor Abbott is bolstering the razor
wire fence along a border park that's at
the center of the dispute GOP leaders
including the governors of at least
seven states are backing Abbot in this
showdown with Biden meantime the
president is facing growing calls from
Democrat lawmakers to federalize the
dexas National Guard but Abbott says he
is not backing
down and what Texas is asserting is our
Article 1 Section 10 right of
self-defense because the president of
the United States is not fulfilling his
duty to enforce the laws passed by
Congress that deny illegal entry into
the United States the Biden
Administration has really truly
abdicated it's responsibility to secure
the border and enforce the laws Texas
very simply is securing the border and
so we put up the razor wire that you
were talking about Bill and we put up
all these barricades that actually have
denied illegal entry and as you pointed
out also in that seding that there are
criminals coming across our border Texas
has a right as a state to stop criminals
from coming into our state to make
arrest of those criminals the
immigration system and the Border issue
is the primary issue in America right
now this is an issue upon which Joe
Biden gets a grade of F and deserves to
be
fired Ari the governor wrote this in his
statement to the binate Administration
very clearly he said the failure of the
binate administration to fulfill the
duties imposed by article 4 section 4
has triggered Article 1 Section 10 CL 3
which reserves to the state the right
reasons I've already declared an
invasion to invoke Texas's
constitutional authority to defend and
protect itself and he says that
Authority is the supreme law of the land
and supersedes any federal statutes to
the contrary this is almost like a page
out of History it is Texas versus the
president now I don't know about
articles and clauses I do know that the
governor is right and think about think
about simply why is it legal for
Sanctuary cities to defy the federal
government to let illegal immigrants in
but it's not legal for Texas to defy the
federal government to keep illegal
immigrants out it makes no sense so yes
since we know Sanctuary cities are
somehow legal what governor Abbott is
doing is not only legal it's moral it is
the right thing because if you're going
to come to America as we want immigrants
to do as my mother did I'm a first
generation American come here legally
don't come here illegally and good for
governor Abbott for finally doing
something about it cuz Joe Biden won't
Kaye let's talk about what if Texas sort
of has Biden in the corner what if Texas
doesn't comply what is Biden going to do
is he going to send in the military is
he going to force Texas to actively open
the Border there's a lot that could
happen and there's a lot at stake well
progressives are saying it's time for
you to control the federal or the Texas
National Guard so he has pressure from
progressives I I doubt he'll do that
he'll probably let this play out in
court but look these Governors who are
supporting Texas are exactly right you
had Governor Kemp who just came out and
said I support Texas governor Ron
DeSantis just put out a video where he
laid out constitutional law in no
uncertain terms he said Daniel Horowitz
brings up Federalist Paper number 46
which allows the states to mitigate
Federal action in certain circumstances
including this one Article 1 Section 10
you point out the powers given to a
state when there is an invasion and it
can be described as nothing less than
that but for all the people who say
Texas you can't do this CL law doesn't
allow this okay what about President
Biden he is the executive branch he must
enforce the laws of Congress namely the
immigration and nationality act which
says you shall the Attorney General
shall Deport certain classes of illegal
immigrants he's ignoring the laws of
Congress so don't give us an education
lesson and constitutional law Mr
President go back and read the constit
because you're defying the laws of
Congress and we have that video Kay so I
want to play it for viewers this is
Governor Landry and Governor DeSantis
who are both standing by Abbott this is
this is their support
watch we support legal not illegal
immigration we stand with governor abbit
and Texas in reminding the federal
government that under our Constitution
states are still Sovereign and we have
the right to protect our citizens if the
Constitution was originally understood
to mean that a state could not protect
itself against an invasion that the
federal government could force a state
to allow an invasion the Constitution
would have never been ratified in the
first place all of this is just nonsense
what Biden's doing uh Texas has every
right to standard ground it's not just a
Texas issue it's ultimately an American
issue and if we don't have sovereignty
in this country uh then we're not going
to be a country
anymore and Marie in addition to voicing
their support and articulating why
legally it is sound um you know danta
says essentially every state is a border
state right now and that's reflected for
example Fox News poll 41% of Americans
say it's the number one top issue I
argue you can't really call it
immigration you can it's a larger bucket
of a secure National sovereignty and
it's not playing out that way in Biden's
eyes well look I agree that it's a very
important issue for voters for a number
of reasons you're absolutely right it's
not Biden versus Texas though it's
actually the Supreme Court I mean the
Supreme Court this week weighed in and
ruled against Texas in one of the issues
related to the border that he was trying
to do so you can't decide when you like
Supreme Court decisions and when you
don't Democrats have had to learn that
the hard way at times so I think the
Supreme Court will increasingly be
weighing in here but I found very
interesting reporting we're getting
today that Donald Trump and his allies
are pressuring republicans in Congress
not to come to some sort of compromise
on the border and immigration we
actually know that they're getting
pretty close senators from both parties
are working very hard here yesterday
Mitch McConnell told the Republican
caucus that they're in a tough position
because Trump doesn't actually want
Biden to be able to quote get a win on
this by signing something even though
signing that piece of bipartisan
legislation would help with the Border
it wouldn't fix it but it would help
there are a lot of there are a lot of
Republicans who believe that this
compromise Democrats control the Senate
and Republicans control the house we
have to compromise they are close Donald
Trump is telling his allies not to vote
for it so he can run on it in November
that to me is D eltion of Duty Biden is
ready to sign something if Congress will
send it to him and Republic Republicans
should get Republicans didn't need to
hear that from Donald Trump the votes
weren't there before Donald Trump said
that's why Mitch McConnell said what he
did you just FR have count votes there's
not enough support for a compromise yes
you just framed it Like Donald Trump
swanned into the Senate and is bullying
Mitch McConnell that is horse manure
that is exactly the way that it was
written by the media but I know Myriad
Republicans in the house nothing was
going to get past them not in an
election year and it is not with the
voters either the first thing that Joe
Biden tried to do when he got into
office was an asylum Bill to Grant every
illegal migrant in this country Asylum
and to also give those who Trump
deported to let them return legally
Nancy Pelosi cuz she's a smart
politician she wouldn't even take it up
so everybody listening needs to remember
that when Kar Jean Pierre and all the
Liars in the Biden Administration bring
up that's the Republicans fault and I
just want to highlight that the likes of
Greg kasar the Democrat representative
from the Texas house and waim Castro
when they tell Joe Biden to federalize
the Texas National Guard yeah please try
to send the military to seiz the border
and ensure that illegal migrants
continue to flow into this country and
to violate the very law that Joe Biden
is supposed to enforce because from sea
to shining sea and in every town and
city in this country people are going to
vote for any Republican to make sure
that this
stops and I have to insert this about
the Supreme Court so the Supreme Court
decision that just came out this week
that was regarding an injunction in the
while we for the right it's while we
wait for the the final just a quick fact
Democrats controlled the house the
Senate and the presidency for two years
they did nothing they had an opportunity
to do it what did they do they took 89
executive actions to roll back Trump's B
policy those are facts inescapable facts
and that Supreme Court it wasn't a
decision it wasn't an opinion it kicked
it back to the fifth circuit this will
continue legally yep hey everyone I'm
Emily compano catch me and my co-hosts
Harris vulner and Kaye mckin on
outnumbered every weekday at 12:00 p.m.
Eastern or set your DVR also don't
forget to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page for daily highlights